what was the first crime you committed
the first mortgage I ever did a mortgage
is me borrowing money from a bank to buy
a house yeah how can you find a way to
commit crime in this how can you do
fraud in this space it's it's very
difficult for the average guy to commit
fraud because there's so many safeguards
set up um you know if you were to go in
and say um make $300,000 a year okay
well we want your W2s we want your pay
stuffs we're going to call your employer
we're going to check to make sure your
employer how long they've been in
corporated we're going to check to make
sure they're registered we're g it's
like ah your whole plan fell apart you
know because the average guy can't do
that he can't even come up with the with
the pce 7 W2 so the average person you
know or I'm going to put down this much
money but you're going to borrow that
money from the seller you know okay well
then they start asking for bank
statements where did the money come from
how how long has it been in your bank
like you can't even have it put in your
bank for a day get a letter you know
it's got to been there for 90 days or 60
days depending on the bank and and so
there's all these ways for the average
person it's very difficult to commit
fraud the average guy that works at
Walmart and makes $6,000 a year and he's
been there for five years and he saved
his deposit like it's a very that's
really the guy that those transactions
are set up for to borrow a mortgage from
Bank of America that's the guy they're
looking for so to commit fraud in this
space have to misrepresent some aspect
of your identity of how much you're
worth how much money you have this kind
of stuff right you have to be able to to
lie to the bank anytime you lie to the
bank you've committed fraud and it's
funny when I was you know doing it I
would say ah it's it's in the gray area
there's no gray area you're either lying
in some capacity or you're not
so it's it for instance the very first
loan I did I I wided out um my borrower
had been 30 days late on her uh on her
rent so they're really looking at the
last two years so when when you go into
the bank and they most of what they're
asking is a is a two-year window they're
saying how long have you been on their
job they care about two years and how
long have you been at your um at your
residency they're looking for two years
now you could be at three places in two
years that's fine as long as you
consistent consistently paid for two
years well she had been in an apartment
complex but she'd been 30 days late now
she caught it up but she was late Bank
the bank doesn't want to lend you money
if if you've been 30 days late so I was
a broker and I Whited out the 30-day
late I just got rid of it and my manager
is the person that told me to do it she
said it'll be fine and she was right it
was what did it feel like so that was
the first fraudulent action you committ
ited yeah I I
mean I you know I I was I was worried
you know I always say you know I sweated
bullets for you know four or five days
you know but I mean I I I was concerned
and and I don't know that I was
concerned that I had broken the
law uh I was concerned because I was
behind on my on my truck payment I was
behind on my mortgage like I had banked
on being a mortgage broker and I'd go
gone deep deep behind on all my bills to
do this so in the last minute when this
loan isn't going to close and I have to
commit fraud to make that happen and the
idea my fear was they were going to
figure it out and maybe I'd get fired
you know I didn't think I was going to
go to jail because my manager assured me
you're not going to jail like they'll
you'll get fired at at
best so my concern was they were going
to catch it and I get fired and I
wouldn't get paid like I needed that
money so bad
so maybe paint the picture here where
were you working who was the manager the
manager what it's funny because I I I
don't think I ever really mentioned this
it her name was uh Gretchen Zas she
eventually I don't mind saying she
eventually got ended up going to jail
for fraud her name was Gretch and Zas
and she was the manager I was working
for a company called Eagle lending and
it was in
Tampa and I this was like my first month
so my very first deal three or four
weeks into it into that first month and
I walk in I put the file in front of my
manager she looks through everything you
know oh great good good and put this one
piece of paper over here MH and sat
there and then when she was done I said
uh what's what's going on she goes
perfect files perfect she goes but your
borrow was 30-day late on her rent and
she says that that's it's done she's
like that's a deal killer and I was like
oh my gosh you know what do I do and I
remember she pulled out a w thing a
white out remember the white out not the
sticks with the one and she started
going and I was like what she go if I
was you and she handed she said I'd
white it out make a copy stick it back
in the file yeah she said it'll be fine
and I went I could I was like that
that's fraud I could go to jail and she
goes and she was like it's they're never
going to catch it she said look we do
stuff I do stuff all the time she said
they're not going to catch it and
nobody's calling the FBI she was the
worst case that that worst case scenario
if underwriting catches
it then they'll fire you that's it
nobody's calling you're not going to
jail and I was you know I trusted her I
was like
okay and so I I did what she said I
stuck it in the file and I mean look
like I said for four or five days I was
like oh my God I'm so scared how old do
you at this point probably 29 I think it
was 29 you know like I had gone to
college and so many things had not
worked out you know I got a degree in
Fine Arts it's not it's not a uh there's
not a lot of people looking for anyone
with a fine arts degree and uh you know
I tried my I tried to be
a uh tried to be a an insurance adjuster
tried that for about a year year and a
half that didn't work out uh ended up
ended up working
construction for a few
years and you know so finally the girl I
was dating said you got to be a mortgage
broker you know she's just had just
started as a Mortgage in the mortgage
industry and she was like you have to do
this like you were born to do this this
is perfect for you what did she see in
you she said just you're salesman and I
was like cuz I was like you know I
barely balanced my checkbook like I
don't I don't know anything about
numbers and she was like it has nothing
to do with that it's sales it's putting
together deals you know you're good at
that you're good at negotiating you're
you know you're a naal sales
salesman and I figured i' I need to try
something so what aspect of more
mortgagees is sales and deal making and
what aspects require the Charisma that
you clearly have well one you've got you
have clients that have lots of options
they can go to Bank of America they can
go to Sun Trust they can go to Chase
they have options if they have perfect
credit I ended up working for a company
that was a subprime lender and those
people didn't have a lot of options by
Honestly by the time they got to that to
Eagle lending their options were over so
what ended ends up happening is you're
negotiating with
sellers you know you would think that a
lot of the stuff that in that industry
that real estate
agents should do you the Brokers end up
doing because real estate agents are are
used to you meet them at the house or
they take you to several houses they you
know they they open the door they walk
around they write up a contract that's
legit a legit contract and you already
you're already
pre-approved everything works out but
subprime that's not the case you got
borrowers with horrific job history they
don't have enough of the down payment
they can't maybe they have the down
payment but they don't have the closing
cost so you have to go to the real
estate agent and say listen I need you
to raise the purchase price and have the
the seller pay the closing costs which
is legal but that's not to a degree but
that's not how they wrote up the
contract so now you're having to get
them to rewrite the contract or you're
have you're you know there's little
things you're trying to do and the more
the more deals you get done and the more
you deal with certain real estate agents
the more you start to
realize that they're you know you know
which ones are completely above board
and which ones are willing to twist the
rules and a lot of it works on personal
relationships right right for some
reason people t tend to like me and
trust me yeah I don't know why it's it's
it hasn't worked out for so many people
but people naturally seem to trust me
and so if I say hey I can close the loan
but you got to do this it'll be cool
don't worry we do it all the time it's
like my third loan and you know I I've
been doing this for years and they go
okay and then they raise the purchase
price they add some money they have the
seller of the house give the borrower
some money they stick it in the bank or
they put it in the in escrow at the
closing company like now you're starting
to massage deals what was the second
time you committed a crime so what how
did it start to evolve from the white
out well I mean when that went through
you know
I I think a normal person probably would
have
said wow it was a onetime thing got away
with it I'm good but for me it just
emboldened me mhm like I just got a
check for like I don't know what it was
25 $3,500 I was thrilled and by that
time I was already working on another
deal but that
guy he made I forget something like he
had made like let's say
$45,000 the year before in his
W2 if you based on
his based on his current track record or
or his year-to date of his pay stub he
made just enough money but if you
factored in last year's
W2 he was shy so if I changed that
45,000 to
51,000 then he could the loan closes I
get a check for 3500 bucks he gets into
a house I'm doing him a favor you know
I'm doing God's work so I fix it it I
kick back I'm terrified a little bit you
know worried about it sure enough it
closes four or five days later they call
me he's ready to close a week later we
close I get a check next guy that comes
in I mean I got very very quick
L I was concerned do you have a house do
you have a deal is it ready I can get
you I can get you done now if you were
in bankruptcy or something there's some
things you just You' pull their credit
and you just couldn't help them if they
were if they had a 550 credit score or
something and no job I mean you know it
had to be within reason but very quickly
it was changing W2s changing pay subs
changing appraisals um you know fixing
verif like I said verifications of
rent so it evolved very quickly for me
and you're essentially helping people
that's what I told myself giving them a
chance people that have been really
struggling financially in life so you've
been telling yourself that this is
you're doing a good good thing for
people I told myself that right up until
that those loans were solid and I was
helping those people out right up until
I went to prison and and I was in prison
and I had to write
the government asked me to write an
ethics and fraud course for to help
teach the nation's mortgage
brokers um you know all loan officers
and Brokers have to take I think it's
nine hours of continuing education every
single year and I was approached to
write the ethics
course and it was about that time and
about the same period of time I was
writing uh writing a book my
book and that kind of used I started
reflecting on what I had done you know
and the truth is
like and this is a horrible thing to say
cuz the first time I ever heard somebody
say this I remember thinking oh that's a
horrible thing to say some people should
not own a house they shouldn't be
allowed to borrow they're not in a
position financially you know and and
there were there were many occasions
where I put someone in a house that they
100% swore they could afford it was I
was helping them I told myself I was
helping them and a year and a half later
ler they're going into foreclosure their
stuff's on the corner they don't know
where to
go and the truth is is that I I'm not
smarter than the actuaries that came up
with those underwriting
guidelines so in this whole process how
are you making money are you taking a
percentage broker fee yeah I charge a
broker fee or you charge yield spread so
yield spread is let's say the interest
rate is 8% interest if I charge them $25
basis points over the 8% so I charge
them 8 and a quarter you know 8.25 then
I get 1% of the loan back as a fee so if
I charge them
85% I get two points back so if it's
$100,000 piece of property and the bank
says your interest rate is going to be
8% and I tell you
8.5 and I'm charging you a $3,500 broker
fee now I'm making
$5,500 so on even a $100,000 loan you
could make a nice chunk of change I mean
it's so how much gray area is here you
said that there really isn't when you're
lying or not but I mean you're feels
there is it well every time I changed
something it wasn't gray area I just
committed I just committed fraud at this
level you're either you either meet the
guidelines or someone has massaged it in
such a way that they've committed fraud
that's it and there's now there's
there's tons of ways where you can
commit fraud
and they just can't figure it out does
that make sense like I I mean I've
you've committed fraud and it's like
they've look at the entire they look at
all the documents and they double check
everything and they know there's fraud
in here they just can't find it just
because they can't find it doesn't mean
doesn't mean it wasn't exactly doesn't
mean it wasn't fraud as part of this you
did a lot of fascinating things one of
the things you did you talked about
creating synthetic
people meaning uh creating fake
identities what do what does it take to
do that to do that well so your credit
profile is made up of your you know your
your your name date of birth your
address and you know your social
security number and you know those are
the kind of you know and then there's
other things where you
work that sort of
thing but what people don't realize is
there's so many people out there that
think that the credit bureaus already
know who you are right but but the truth
is the first time the credit bureau has
ever heard about you was when you told
them the first time you applied for a
credit card you they created a credit
profile at that moment prior to that
they had no idea so the first time you
apply you give them your your full name
date of birth social security number and
your
address and they create a credit profile
and they say hey no record found of this
person he has no credit nothing probably
got denied well what I realized through
the course of because eventually I ended
up leaving that one company and I opened
my own mortgage
company when I opened that mortgage
company I
was I was on the inside does that make
sense like I wasn't a I wasn't just a
broker that was sitting out with
everybody else and would periodically
come in and ask questions or would call
underwriting and but really didn't
understand what was happening and what
exactly what the underwriting guidelines
were now I was talking to the
underwriters and you're you're talking
to the um to the owners of The Lending
institutions and the banks and you're
talking to all of the account Executives
and now it wasn't just Eagle lending I
was talking to there were 40 different
account Executives coming in on a weekly
basis trying to get us to sign up with
their lender and they're on the inside
telling you coming in showing you uh
programs and saying look if your
borrower is you know self-employed
we don't ask for this or this we just
ask for them to say they're
self-employed like liar loans you you've
heard the term liar loans okay um where
no doc loans where they don't ask for
any documentation if he's got over like
let's say a 700 credit score and he says
he's been a plumber and he works for
himself then he's got over a 700 credit
score he just has to say he's worked for
himself for over two years and they
don't ask any yet they don't ask for any
documentation he's got the money in the
bank he's got a 700 credit score says
he's been on the job for two years he
self-employed we're going to raise his
insurance rate by
1% and and he's got you know that's it
he's he's got the loan so but you start
to you start to know how things work
because I hired a bunch of Brokers to
work underneath me and when they would
get
caught I would get the phone call so I
get the phone call from the owner of a
bank or a lending Institute you know A
lender and that lender says hey Matt we
got a problem I'm like what's up he's
like he's like listen uh we we caught a
fake W2 I'm like what do what do you
mean yeah your your broker soand so sent
us a file and this person had there's
two fake W2s and we're assuming the pay
subs are fake and I'm like are you
serious how how did you even catch that
and they go oh well here's what we did
we checked with
sunbiz.com you know sunbiz.gov which is
the Secretary of State's website that
registers corporations and we checked
and the tax ID number didn't match and I
now I know every W2 has to have a
matching uh tax ID number for whatever
corporation uh issued it so there's a
sequence of checks they do to detect
fraud on different documents like W2s
right and then you're slowly learning
slowly yeah exactly what's the process
for detecting I mean I had a pretty good
understanding anyway yeah but so I'm
starting to learn that understanding
yeah so I'm putting these things
together and I remember one time I had a
woman come in and she came in and she
had perfect credit she had like 750
credit scores I mean it was perfect and
she came in and uh one of the Brokers
came in and said hey man he's can I show
you something I was like yeah what's up
he he goes look he said I've got this
This Woman's W2s here I said okay I
looked at him and he goes here's your
credit report and he goes here's the you
know application this is the this is the
social security number I went all right
and he said this is the social security
number on the W2 and I went okay keep in
mind you go to get a car loan or credit
card they never asked for these things
so and he was like and I'm really
shocked he even noticed it I probably
might not have even caught it but he
they were different and I went really
and he goes yeah he said um so I I did
you know she just brought them in you
know she's here and I was like oh bring
her in here so she came in sat down and
said listen here's what we just found
and she was like oh okay you know what I
don't want the loan I I just I go no no
no no I said listen you're getting the
loan you got a 750 credit score like I
don't care what we have to do we're
getting you the loan I just want to know
what's going on mhm how are how did you
how did you get 750 credit scores under
this social security number when clearly
this is your real social security number
you've been working for this company for
10 years and your credit profile says
it's only like three years old and I was
like what happened and what she told me
she did was she had been she went
through a divorce she had been married
for 10 years used her husband's I mean
his name for 10 years so she has no
credit under her maiden name mhm but
when they got divorced she switched to
her maiden
name um because when she pulled tried to
get anything in her in her um husband's
surname it was denied bad credit so he
had bad credit their credit went bad so
he switched to her she switched to her
name and a friend told her if she needed
to get her electric or anything turned
on she could use her name and use her
daughter's or son's social security
number which was like a four-year-old
kid yep so she used that and it went
through she had to put a deposit down
but it went through at least wasn't
denied so that went through then she
went and she applied for an apartment
with
that sure enough it went through she had
no credit but they said you don't have
bad credit so she said once she moved
into the apartment she then started
getting these preapproved credit cards
so she she goes but I knew I had applied
there
using my son's social security number
let's say so she started filling those
out and sure enough she got a credit
card and then she got to and then she
got a pre-approval from Ford Motor
Credit she went and got herself a new
car got approved she's been making the
payments ever since she had 750 credit
scores she thought she'd try her hand at
buying a house in his name in his social
security number
and we caught it and she got a house in
that name we we closed it I just was
like wow like this is great can I ask
you a question about that because it
seems like she's able to pay for
everything right so while this is highly
illegal is it unethical is it
like it's it's unethical in that it's
messing with the system on which a lot
of people
rely but it feels like there's some
aspect of the system that's broken in
that it doesn't give people like her a
second chance she could have claimed
bankruptcy and then two years later
listen two years out of bankruptcy you
can go into Bank of America and get a
conventional mortgage assuming you have
perfect credit outside the bankruptcy
you have the down payment you make
enough money there's a whole bunch of
you know a bunch of uh underwriting
guidelines you have to meet but that's
possible but you're right for instance
she wasn't getting an apartment using
with her bad credit she wasn't getting
her utilities turned on she wasn't
getting any of those things done so
getting your life back on track is just
harder it's extremely hard so there's a
temptation to take the shortcut and the
shortcut is often going to be illegal
right and she stumbled into it but she
basically explained it to me and I I
mean I don't think she had walked out of
the of my brokerage office before I went
and I just started making up you know
names and I think I went I went and into
our file cabinet and grabbed some
people's uh 1040s which we had you
know their tax returns and looked up
children's Social Security numbers and
just grabbed some random kid Social
Security numbers and their name and went
and pulled them and sure and you know
but I changed their date of birth to be
an adult pulled it and sure enough it
came up no file found you know it didn't
say fraud alert or fraud or anything
didn't say mismatch this mismatch that
didn't say anything it just said you
know no file found well
then we went and we pulled applied for a
couple credit cards using a child's
social security number and then we went
and pulled Our Own Credit Report and
sure enough it didn't say no no file
found it just said that there had been
two
inquiries applying for credit cards so I
was like wow like that's a credit
profile so that turns into
me going to Social
Security and calling or calling Social
Security and trying to get them to issue
me Social Security numbers to adults
that had never had a social security
number issued to them I need to get
Social security number to give me a
clean social security number but I
called up and of course you know I'm a
novice I don't really know what I'm
doing so I call up and I say hey uh yeah
I was I'm uh never had a Social Security
Number issue and they were like how old
are you and I was like um 31 years old
you know and they were yeah that's not
possible do you have a driver's license
uh yeah you have a bank account yeah you
have a Social Security number uh bring
your driver's license in and we'll we'll
pull it up okay well that's not going to
happen hang up call back hi um my
son is 7 years old or three years old
and he he had never had a social
security number issued oh okay was he
born in a hospital yes well he has one
he has one go ahead and uh get your son
come in here no I'm not doing that hang
up call back so I called back probably
times and
eventually uh someone said I I kept
altering it
kept altering what I was saying till I
got to the point where I was
saying my son was born with a midwife
not in the hospital and the pediatrician
told us that we needed to go we need to
get Social Security to issue a social
security number and they would say well
he should have issued it but that does
happen sometimes so bring your son in
and we'll you know you can fill out the
paperwork will'll have one issued MH you
know first we'll check to see he never
had one issued and if he hasn't we'll
issue one and so then it turned into my
son is out of the country and I need
this and then that turned into oh I'm
sorry well how old is he I was like um
you know he's three and they go well I'm
sorry if he's over the age of 12 months
old he has to come in hang up the phone
call back my son is 10 months old he's
out of the country born with a midwife
never had a social security number and
then they go oh okay okay that's fine
just get his birth certificate and a
shop his shop record and you can come in
fill out the paperwork we'll get issue
you a social security number and that's
what I did so I figured out how to
create a birth certificate you know I
ordered the security paper you know when
uh where you make a copy it says you
know void if copied so I ordered had to
order a bunch of that and I went online
and figured out how to make a a fake
birth certificate it was great too
because like the county actually they
give you a a blank form and then they
actually show you what it looks like
filled out like a handwritten one filled
out so I knew if he was born this day he
got these shots um two months later he
got these shot six months later he got
these shot so I just filled it out I
even had to order a a seal so you have
to have a seal that says like Hillsboro
County vital statistics or Richland
County vital statistics or something and
I couldn't get anybody to make that so I
changed it to like Richland County
Office of
virtual um records and then I took like
220 grit sandpaper and and and HIIT it
over and over and over again to wear it
down and then I State you know I did the
embossment on the on the corner and you
know I printed it on the security paper
embossed it nobody looks at those things
you can see Richland County you know you
you could kind of see that and really
they just grab it and they go like this
this is what you realize after you when
I started getting
started getting uh driver's licenses
issued by uh by the State DMV right the
state I I figured out eventually it was
easier to just go into the DMV and have
them give me a a driver's license than
actually make one so but you notice they
would just grab the thing they feel the
form and go okay like they don't even
look at it so which is upsetting if you
put as much work into these documents as
I am for them to go okay yeah that's
good sit over there I felt like going
like hey bro like a look at this this is
artwork yeah but they're looking for the
lwh hanging fruit of crappy fraud right
yeah this stuff was right through so
okay so so birth certificate gets you a
uh Social Security number so it's it's
it's interesting because you've also you
you've done a lot of different
approaches to um creating synthetic
people there's homeless people involved
so sometimes it's grounded in real
people or real name
names and then you're right like some
part is fake some part is real sometimes
and sometimes it's completely all fake
right cuz now I have the name I have the
social security number and what's great
is they mail you what's even better is
you get then you get to pick whatever
name you want you know CU when you pick
your child's name he doesn't even have
to have your last name you pick any name
so I would pick a name and i' just say
oh my wife's last name is this if it
they questioned it which they never did
but you know I've got a social security
number and then I would go apply for
credit cards and i' get denied of course
but they would all offer me a secured
credit card so I I'd then fill out the
secured credit card and I'd send them
send the bank the money and they would
give me a secured credit card for $500
$300 a th000 whatever it was and then
once you start making the
payments I pulled the credit and a
credit profile shows up saying that this
31y old man with a social security
number that I know was issued
you know a couple months ago has three
three credit cards they don't even say
secure they just say there's like this
credit card is $500 it was issued by
Bank of America this one was issued by
Capital One this one so I've got three
of them but I had no credit
scores so at that point I kind of kicked
back and waited and I just kept making
payments and I remember thinking to
myself I'll bet you they don't that the
credit bureaus don't generate credit
scores for at least a year I was like
God this is going to be a year-long
process and while that was happening I
started other I was starting other ones
cuz I figured at least in a year I'll
have a bunch of these secure you know
these um we call them like Phantom
borrowers but now they call them
synthetic identities so at least I would
have these synthetic identities and
maybe I could do something with them but
what happened was at six months I went
and I randomly pulled the guy's credit
you know the person's credit and had
705 credit scores 705 701 695 I was like
oh my go you only needed a 620 to borrow
to get a 95% loan from the bank so I was
like oh my God this is in this is
amazing sure enough a month later the
other ones I had started all of them Bam
Bam Bam so what do you do with a phantom
borrower like what how do you make money
on this so I think most people if you
were just like a scammer a fraudster you
would you would probably just get credit
cards and maybe build up that history or
maybe try and borrow a personal loan uh
which is limited you know it's personal
loans are used to be you used to be you
could go
to uh an FDIC insured bank which borrows
money
those you know the personal loans they
lend out at the max $155,000 you know so
you could do that so you can go through
this whole process creating a fake
identity getting a card paying it off
building up credit and then you get
$115,000 at the end or so right you get
15 maybe you know if you want to keep
making the payments you know if you
could wait a year you could probably get
15,000 uh maybe you could maybe get 20
30,000 and a bunch of little smaller
ones you know you get 7500 because I did
I did there was $7,500 from City Bank
you know $5,500 from American General so
you maybe get what 25,000 you know maybe
30,000 in personal loans maybe you can
you could you could then apply for you
maybe get another 20 or 30,000 in
regular credit cards you know 10,000
here 8,000 5,000 and then you go to the
lower department store cards and you go
to Home Depot you get a th000 you get
500 so it ends up being maybe you can
get 50 60,000 maybe if you really good
you could get up to$ 80 or $100,000 in
credit cards and personal loans if you
really knew what you were doing but per
person per identity per identity but I
had the ability to
to leverage that perfect those perfect
credit profiles against
properties and I mean ultimately that's
what I end up doing and and so each one
of those identities was
worth you know a few million you explain
how that works so uh to leverage them
against property so how does that work
with the mortgage so what I did
eventually I mean this would like is
down the road but you know I mean at
this point when things are just my whole
life had kind of gone off the The
Rails I was on federal probation and and
so what I did decided I was going to do
was start running a scam a much larger
scam and what I was going to do was it I
was going to start flipping properties
right like buy houses cheap fix them up
and sell them there's an area of Tampa
called eore
City so I was going to start flipping
houses in eor city and you know I
thought okay I can I can buy these
houses for you could buy a really crappy
house at that time for 50 $60,000 let's
say 50 and then you could put $225,000
into it in renovations you could
renovate it for 25 and maybe you could
get an appraisal for a
hundred so I thought what I could do is
I
can I can buy these houses renovate them
and sell them to you know regular
people
but I also had been working on the
synthetic identities and then I thought
well or I could just sell them to
synthetic identities and then I wouldn't
have to dump 25,000 into it right and
these guys are perfect they have perfect
credit I can provide W2s and pay stubs
because by this point I'm
manufacturing
businesses so I've got I've got I've
Incorporated businesses I've got
websites for the businesses W2s payub so
these guys have these guys look perfect
so I figured I'll buy these properties
for 50,000 sell it to these guys for 100
maybe I'll pocket 40 or 50,000 I don't
really have to do
anything but that seem shortsighted so I
thought what would be even better is
that if I did a little bit of
Renovations and then I sold it for much
higher maybe I put 10,000 clean up the
outside of it because these guys don't
care what the inside of of the property
looks like you know they they're not
they don't exist
so and then I but I can't how am I going
to get an appraisal for
$100,000 well do you you know how
appraisals work okay so the bank sends
an appraiser out or at that time you
could provide an appraisal they can
review it so they'll do what's called a
Desktop review they review it they
review it
on um on the computer they never go out
to the property or they send someone out
they they call that you know it's like a
field review they send someone out and
they just look at the house they don't
go in it though so I have to clean out
the clean up the outside of the house so
what I did was
but the problem is is if your house is
you're trying to sell that house for
let's say 200,000 the other houses they
have to pick three comparable sales in
the area that are also going to support
a a
$200,000 sales price well there's no
other houses selling for $2 200,000 near
this house so I thought if I want to get
these things appr praise for 200
250,000 I have to have comparable sales
and that appraisal is going to be
reviewed so what I did
was I started I went out and I bought
this house for
50,000
and I recorded the sale at
$200,000 So when you buy a house for
$100,000 you pay $700 in dock
stamps but if you pay the extra an extra
700 bucks the sale shows up for
200,000 I'm buying these things for 50
so I'm paying $350 and I'm just paying
an extra
$1,00
50 so I'm so it ends up being you know
$1,400 but the but the sale shows up at
$200,000 on a house that's a a crack
house I bought for
$50,000 now I go I trim the trees we mow
the yard we clean up the porch we put a
porch rail on maybe we paint it real
nice we black out all the windows you
can't see inside um but from the from
the curb it looks great and I get an
appraisal so I do that with that house I
do that with another house all within a
mile so I buy four houses knowing I
could
use the all there's a subject and three
comparables for all of them so the first
thing I did is I bought four houses for
50,000 60,000 40,000 and I recorded the
values at you know 210 20000
190 so I get an appraiser to come out
there he appraises it he said of course
he says it's horrible but there's
comparables here now of course it is in
bad shape and he says it's in bad shape
but I I go ahead and I correct all that
so I correct it so now if you if you
review the appraisal and you're in
California or even if you drive your car
down your the appraiser comes to the
house and looks at it from the street it
looks fine but the truth is I've got
$660,000 into this property and you're
appraising it for $200,000 so the bank's
rated not they're not going to lend 200
but they'll in 190 so the bank is ready
to
lend this synthetic
borrower $190,000 on a house that I have
60,000 in so I walk so I schedule a
closing and we close on the house and I
walk away with
$60,000 you know and and the thing is
like the problem was is by the time I
got to this point I knew so many people
in the industry I nobody had to really
at that point show up although I've had
people show up for the synthetic
identies and sign for them almost all
the closings nobody ever showed up I
just showed up and said to the title uh
to the title agency and said hey my
borrower he's at work right now he can't
make it can I just take the file and
I'll have him sign all the documents at
his work and I'll bring him back he's
like an hour and a half away from here
I'll be back in 2 or three hours they're
like oh wow that man man thank you so
much and they would give it to me and
I'd go sit in the parking lot and I'd
sign all the documents and i' wait an
hour or two and I'd come back in and say
here you go H how are you able to keep
all this in your mind because you have
to not slip up in any of these
conversations it's pretty easy for me to
for me to keep
them everything in the correct category
does that make sense like it's it's I'm
not great at a lot of things but this I
was very good at but well there's these
Phantom people that exist and they were
becoming real people in your mind is
then like you're able to tell good
stories with with those people right
like because if you're talking to the
appraiser if you're talking to the
everybody in involved well keep in mind
the appraiser almost never meets the
borrower never not even like 99.99 99%
of the time they never meet them but you
have to talk about them yeah so I guess
what I'm asking is you're able to
Converse fluently about these synthetic
identities yeah they they all had
different jobs they all had all the jobs
were basically they were all on the job
for five years they were all it was a
lot of it was there's a template yeah
exactly but I got it listen all matter
of fact almost every one of them had the
same birth date you know so because I
you know who knows um there's so it it
yeah it wasn't difficult and keep in
mind the a lot of the the Brokers barely
ever meet
um meet the bar they call in on the
phone but it didn't matter anyway
because I'm walking in saying I got a
slam dunk deal for you and they're like
oh wow Matt you got the W2s the pay
stubs you've got all the you got all
their uh their rental history you have
everything done it's perfect thank you
so much they're happy to do it hey I
print up the docs and I'll have them go
sign it great wow thank you you know
assuming they didn't already know about
it almost everybody involved in this by
the time I was done was involved there
was probably 15 or 20 people that all
knew was going on the full of it they
knew the full depth of it yes yeah at
yeah maybe not 100% everything but they
definitely knew this is fraud and they
were still going along with it yeah yeah
keep in mind that even when I give you
an
example one of
my you know let's take and this happened
with almost all of them was he would buy
five
houses so the guy but what happens the
basic design was I buy the
houses I record the values
higher
and this person buys all five houses
refinances them he ends up borrowing a
little bit over a million dollar in his
name uh then of course then I go and I I
get um personal loans from several Banks
I get credit cards I run up all of his
credit cards by this point I've got1
$20,000 worth of credit cards in the
guy's name so the guys are all worth
like a million million and change well
once I stop paying you start getting
letters from the collection companies
right from the banks you know and then
they sell them off so after about three
months you're getting tons of letters
and what I would do is I would take my
borrower's name I would go online and I
would find or i' go in the newspaper and
I would
find I would find an article about let's
say like a 12C car pile up mhm you know
so there's you know a huge accident on
I4 it's very dangerous so there's a 12
car pile up and someone in the accident
was life flighted to Tampa General
hospital I
would cut and paste that
article and I would just insert my
borrower's name into the article saying
that you know Brandon green was LIF
flighted to Tampa General hospitals
currently in critical condition I would
then print that article out on news news
print I then make a copy of the cut it
up make copy of the newsprint Highlight
his name and I would write a letter from
Brandon
Green's fictional sister to the
collection companies saying several
months ago my brother was in a horrible
car accident he is currently they've got
the article they have the highlighted
name he clearly was in in this uh in
this accident he is currently in a coma
and the doctors say even if he wakes up
from the coma he will never work again
that you know so you might as well just
foreclose on stop writing us letters and
take the houses back and that's all
they're looking for is is is a reason at
this point even if they look into
Brandon green they can't figure out if
he's a real person or
not because he's got a social security
number he's got and everything went bad
at the same time he's got multiple
rental properties or his primary
residence all of his credit cards went
bad everything went bad we have an
excuse we have a letter that happens
people get divorced they lose their job
they get in accidents it's reasonable
when they look into it all looks
legitimate even if they ordered another
appraisal by this point it's not four
comparable sales or three or four
comparable sales by this point it's like
10 15 20 30 40 50 because I kept making
more and more of these guys what was
your just almost like a tangent what's
your thinking process there's a lot of
cleverness going on here so like uh the
the car pileup as a solution newspaper
and you mail
it what are you sitting there alone and
thinking through this like how do you
come up with that idea it's a it's a
very interesting a very clever
Innovative idea so at first I I thought
about making like a a fake death
certificate M he died you know but I
thought I don't know like what if you
know like some of these places had like
you know uh you know primary mortgage
insurance like what if the primary
mortgage insurance like what if they try
claim cuz he was dead or like I don't
know I don't know that side so I'm like
I don't want to do that I want to do
something that's semi- verifiable and
third party it's like a third party
telling you this is what happened I
thought well like the newspaper you know
and you know or do I claim bankruptcy
and I've done that I've gone and got the
bankruptcy forms right you can go to the
bankruptcy court and they'll give you
forms to mail to all of your uh
creditors and you mail them they stop
contacting they wait to be no located by
or notified by the bankruptcy court but
my fear there is you know nobody's ever
going to notify them like I'm not going
through bankruptcy for one of these guys
so it was like this is a this is a
better bet than just writing a letter
saying I'm going through a divorce my
wife's keeping those houses that's her
problem you know you could do there's
lots of things you could do but to me
this was they're not going to try and
how do you how do you shut it down
without him dying how do you shut that
down this is how you shut it down he's
in a coma he'll never work again he was
in a car accident here's the proof he
can't even write you I'm a sister I
wrote you the letter it's a onetime
letter that seems to um tie up
all
exactly you know I get all know the ex
exactly how
that you know what sparked that is as
much as there were so many other avenues
that I could have gone that I was I just
didn't know but you were thinking
through all those different Avenues are
you mostly thinking
alone I mean you know I had guys that I
was bouncing ideas ideas off of there
were other guys that were involved in
the scam you know everybody I think that
scam ended up making like I think the
FBI said it was like 11 and a half
million or something and and you know
but but there were so many other people
that were involved in that scam that
were you know this guy's getting 50 this
guy's getting 20 you know 177,000 20,000
25,000 and you know the we're just doing
it constantly and so the bank would
foreclose on that property theyd take it
back they put it back on the MLS they
put it back on the MLS for 100 for
200,000 it wouldn't sell then they drop
it to you know 150 wouldn't sell then
they drop it to 125 130 wouldn't sell
they drop it to 90 and somebody buy it
for like 90 it wasn't worth 90 but by
that point that whole area had we' done
so many houses at that point the whole
area shot up and the the FBI said uh we
did 109 houses I don't think that's true
but
but wow we we when I end up leaving
Tampa after that scam falls apart and
the FBI shows up Forbes came out with an
article whatever six months later and
they
said that the ebore City ZIP code was
one of the top 20 fastest growing z um
appraising areas in the country and you
know everybody was like oh that's mad CU
this place is a dump like this is is a
horrible place like this is and I
remember one time I had talked to a guy
you know years later and he was like ah
all the comparable sales have dried up
like when you left there was just
nothing even close to
200,000